So, good evening everyone, and let's begin in the name of the Father and of the Son and
of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose
of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother
Mary and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine, will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear
from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, that I remain so docile to the movements
of your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your
requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my
forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light so that I may understand
the truth and the goods that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
So I want to begin in May the 30th, 1925.
Here we're talking about free will, which is terribly important for especially for our
upcoming consecration.
Louisa said I was feeling oppressed because of the loss of my adorable Jesus.
Oh how I longed for his return she said, I called him one with my heart, two with my
voice and three with my thoughts.
So I want to remind you there of Deuteronomy 6 verses 4 to 10 that you should love the
Lord your God with all your heart and all your soul and all your mind and all your being.
And you see that Louisa is doing that.
Oh God she said how long the nights are without Jesus while together with him they go like
a single breath.
And as I was saying my love do not leave me I am too little I need you and you know that
my littleness cannot be without you and yet you leave me come back come back Jesus.
And as she was crying this at that very moment Jesus extended one arm around her neck and
he made himself seen as a child pressing he said so very strongly against the inside of
her chest not the outside.
So he's actually showing himself from within he's trying so very hard to tell this woman
that he is with her all the time he does not leave her at all.
So there I want to give you Luke 17 21 again and one Corinthians 3 16 the kingdom of God
is within you and she said that he was knocking his head against her chest to the point that
she felt was going to break down.
I think he was trying to get a point through to her that he's tried so hard to say in words.
So she said is she even trembled and feared and Jesus with strong and gentle voice told
me my daughter do not fear it is I that's ego Amy it is I that's what Jesus said to the
apostles on the sea Matthew 14 27 do not fear it is I do not be afraid.
I do not leave you and besides how could I leave you the living in my will renders the
soul inseparable from me you know we need to really look at this in the early volumes
Jesus spoke about his blessed mother as inseparable from him in recent volumes he began to refer
to Louisa as inseparable from him and now he says that any soul that lives in the divine
will is inseparable from him naturally because if the divine will takes over then the same
will that ruling in heaven is ruling in your heart as well so he says my life is for her
more than the soul to the body and just as the body without the soul turns back into dust
because it lacks the life that sustains it in the same way without my life within yourself
you would remain empty of all the acts that my will does in you that emptiness that would
be a very awful void to have you would no longer hear my voice in the depths of your soul repeating
and whispering to you the way to have you carry out your office in my will so if the divine
will is in fact raining within us then it means that in the depths of your soul you do in fact
perceive not only the presence of God but you do in fact perceive what is communicating to you
and then he said logically if there is my voice there is also my life because it's it's his life
that amidst the will and the voice how easily you think that I might leave you he said I cannot
do it if they're inseparable he can't do it because everything that God does is eternal and
everything that God does is immutable so if Louisa gave her yes many years ago as far as God is
concerned that's it it's done but for you to leave my will would also be difficult he said
almost in fact impossible in other words once the fiat is given there's no divorce
once the surrender is given there is no divorce that's it forever that's the incredible thing that
you actually die with the will of God raining in you well if you die with the will of God raining
in you you go straight to heaven because that's where the will of God is raining so what he says
here is actually very important and particularly for all of us who are preparing for this consecration
in August you are in the condition which is almost similar to that of the blessed in heaven now why is
it almost but not yet there it's because on earth we still have pain and suffering and we still have
work to do whereas in heaven there's no pain and no suffering and the work is done this is a wonderful
revelation they have not lost their free will this is a gift that I gave to man and once I give a gift
I never take it back this is extremely important so I want to give you Romans 11 29 to 32 okay God
never ever takes back his gifts slavery has never entered heaven slavery means you do not have the
use of your free will I am the god of sons and daughters not of slaves Galatians 4 6 to 7
I am the king who makes everyone rain Romans 5 17 Paul tells us that we rain with Christ
and there's no division between me and them those of you who are doing revelation with me
know that in chapter 3 that Jesus promised the members of the church who overcame their difficulties
that they would reign with him that he would share his throne with them but the knowledge of my goods
of my will and of my happiness is so great I want you to notice the word knowledge he's
going to continuously tell us the vital role that knowledge has in our ability to give ourselves
to him but the knowledge of my goods and of my will and of that my happiness is so great and so
vast that they are filled with it to the brim to the point of overflowing and their will finds no place
to act they are so overwhelmed by all that they are experiencing in heaven that there is no place
for a separate will and while they are free the knowledge of an infinite will and of infinite goods
in which they are immersed leads them with an irresistible force look at that expression
we've heard Louisa use that expression for quite a number of volumes now it must be at least for
volumes that she's moved by an irresistible force so the divine will is operating very
powerfully within her whether she acknowledges or not so the saints in heaven he has told you at
the beginning of this paragraph that the condition of someone living in the divine will is almost
similar to that in heaven so in heaven the saints are free but the knowledge of an infinite will and
of infinite goods in which they are immersed leads them with an irresistible force to use their will
as if they did not have it now that was the explanation that has been given to us elsewhere
in Louisa's writings about our blessed mother's commitment to the divine will as well that from
the very first instance of her life that she acted as if she didn't have a will of her own
she surrendered it completely and totally to the divine
so they act as if they did not have it considering this their greatest fortune and happiness
but spontaneously free and of their own will now this i cannot underline enough
whatever we do god wants it as a spontaneous response from our innermost being that we actually
want to glorify him then we want to love him that we want to do something to help our brothers and
sisters on earth reach the divine will as well that everything has to be of our own will
i heard of a testimony of a person whose name i can't remember right now
recently and that jesus asked her
would you be would you agree to be a bride of my divine will and she said yes
and he took her in an out of the body experience just like he did it did with louisa he took her
up to heaven and the first question that god the father asked her when she arrived in heaven with
jesus was have you come of your own free will then when i heard that i laughed because here was jesus
coming with somebody he had snatched from the earth god the father wanted to know have you come
of your own free will i think that's marvelous so all the saints in heaven they use their free will
absolutely fully consciously surrendered every single instant of eternity there you have the
the continuous surrender to god which expresses their love for him
and he says it's the same with you making my will known to you has been the greatest grace i have
given you and the same with us the greatest grace is given to us is that we come to know the divine will
and while you are free to do your will or not before mine your will feels incapable of operating
that's because she is surrendered just like the saints in heaven are surrendered
if we if we're not completely surrendered then we know our own will as well as his
so before mine your will feels incapable of operating now we've heard that we used a talk like that for
many volumes it feels annihilated and that's exactly the word that she uses herself
and knowing the great good of my will you abhor yours and without anybody forcing you
you love to do my will in view of the great good that comes to you from it so he's going to
be emphasizing in the messages that follow this that the more we understand the divine will the
more we will choose it and therefore it is absolutely essential to keep on confronting ourselves
with the knowledge of the divine will because it's only as we come to grasp it that we will choose
it more and more until finally we actually lay down the will completely the great knowledge he said
that i have manifested to you about my will forges divine bonds eternal chains that surrounds you
and gives you possession of celestial goods as you the more knowledge
you are confronted with the more knowledge you can actually take on board this is what actually
forges the divine bonds and the chains that enables us to possess these celestial goods
no knowledge no understanding how would you take it he's already a couple of volumes back
given us the example of a person who has a precious gem in their hands but they actually don't know
the value of it and they go to someone to have it evaluated and they're told i'll just
pluck a number out of the sky they're told it's worth a thousand euros so now something he didn't
appreciate is worth a thousand euros then he goes to somebody else and he's told no it's a million euros
so he had this enormous treasure which he was not paying any attention to
he was not evaluating it was knowledge that actually made the difference and so this is what
jesus is going to emphasize a lot here if the human will tries to escape from these eternal chains
and break these divine bonds and lose these celestial possessions also in this life your will
though free does not know how to find the way out now as we go on into the higher volumes
louis is going to say that that when she immerses herself in the divine will there doesn't appear
to be an exit no matter how much she moves or travels so the human will becomes confused
and it sees its littleness and fearing itself which is the very best thing you can hear
that you fear the human will we're inclined to fear the divine will which is the wrong end of
the thing altogether and fearing some trick of its own the human will dives and plunges itself
into the divine will with even more spontaneous love once the surrender is given the human will
is then locked into the divine will forever it's permanent this is the the wonder of the
consecration that we're actually talking about and that means that your will is in the same position
as the saints in heaven that their will is locked into the divine will and they choose to do it
not only do the saints have free will but the angels had free will and they also chose
to lock into the divine will permanently so what he wants now is that people on earth while they're
still on their earthly journey will choose what the angels chose and be human angels
and choose what the saints chose and be saints on earth because if they do that
then all his plans for the human race will be fulfilled it's terribly important now don't forget
it took one fifteen year old to say yes to the Lord for the incarnation to happen
it's going to take all of us in the divine will to say yes to the Lord for him to return
he needs to know he's welcome and he needs to know that he will find his own will on earth
and so the consecration is something that is so much greater than any of us actually suspect
knowledge Jesus said opens the doors of the good which is known and the more knowledge
I have manifested to you about my will the more different doors of goods and light and grace
and of divine sharings I have shared opened with you now what is the door it's knowledge
it's knowledge this is why I've been emphasizing to you from the beginning that we must study
we must read we must pray we must enter into this we must grasp it we must take hold of it we must
internalize it we must make it our own that we don't just say that this is wonderful that
louisa had this out there or that other people have out there we must internalize it and make this
our own Jesus said these doors are open for you I want to give you a few scriptures on that one
Isaiah 22 22 Revelation 3 verses 7 to 8 1 Corinthians 16 verse 19 and 2 Corinthians 2 12
now in Revelation 3 the Lord said the door is open for you I've opened the door for you
and when we when we take this revelation of the divine will the Lord has opened a door for us
to actually enter into this divine life on earth and when we go through it in our surrender
our consecration then it means that he's going to open the doors for his will to be done on earth
as it is in heaven he needs us to go through these doors are open for you and as this knowledge reaches
into the midst of creatures that means the rest of humanity these doors will open for them also
so notice it's important for us to go through in order to let anybody else come through
it's very important we worry about some people that we know and love don't worry about them
just go through the door and they'll follow
the doors will open for them also because knowledge makes love arise for the good that is known if you
really appreciate something you'll love it and you'll want to have it you want to possess it that's
the way human beings are and the first door I will open will be my will in order to close
the little door of the human will we've heard so much about self-denial and
mortification and putting your own will aside and all the rest of it but what Jesus is saying now is
the more you will look into what his divine will will do for you and the marvels and the graces and
the gifts that go with receiving the divine will that's when you will let go the human will
whereas if you try to do it all by yourself in the beginning you only feel the pain but
if you truly wanted a car very very badly you go to trouble to actually pay for it
if you wanted it very badly if you want a house very badly you'll you'll suffer for years paying
a mortgage because you want the house and if we want the divine will it's going to be so much
easier to put aside the human will my will will make them abhor their own because before my will
the human will is incapable of acting with the light of my will it sees how insignificant and good
for nothing it is now we've heard louisa say that throughout all the volumes that is absolutely good
for nothing so i want to give you john 15 5 where jesus says without me you can do nothing and so
as a consequence they will put their will aside so now we're approaching the mystery very differently
than we did in volumes one to four where we were looking at all the mortification and self-denial
and all the big price you have to pay now you're looking at it from the other end if i can put it
this way when a bride is preparing for her wedding she doesn't look at all the trouble she has to go
through and all the expense and all the preparation and this and that you know she has her eyes on the
wedding day and if you keep the divine will in front of your eyes all the time and that you want
everything that god is offering to us then the price is not going to be so hard
moreover you must know that when i manifest to you some knowledge about my will watch this now
only only when you have already let the good of what i've manifested to you enter your soul
only then do i decide to open to you another door of knowledge this is why all of us have had the
experience that you can read these writings and you can go back into a volume you've already
studied and it's fresh why there's an awful lot you didn't get or you understood it intellectually
but it's not the intellectual understanding it is that your soul begins to grasp your soul
begins to take this thing on board and your soul begins to reach out to actually live it and so
when your soul actually reaches out to live this then the next thing actually comes as a
consequence like a and then b and then c and then d and then e and then f one after the other
that's what he's saying only when you've already let the good of what i have manifested to you
enter into your soul then do i decide to open to you another door of knowledge therefore he is
requiring absorption and action as a result of what we have received if i don't do so he said
then yours would only be news or information now the one thing that people don't need
is just head knowledge about the divine will they absolutely don't need it what you need is heart
knowledge and soul knowledge and you need to look at a person and say so that's how the divine will
works in a human being you need to actually see it and when other people see that that infectious
joy and when other people see that totally attractive humility in us and this spontaneous love that
doesn't ask the price they will begin to see that they're looking at something supernatural
and that is the way you advertise divine will not on the internet there it can come across as
information or news so he says if you don't take it on board and actually live it it's only head
knowledge and it would not be the possession of it so if i'm explaining this to somebody
and they can see that this is just head knowledge for me they're not going to take it on board
and even who have taught children in school know that they're reading you the whole time
that you're speaking and they know whether in fact some thing you've taught them in religion
is something you don't believe they know whether it's head knowledge or heart knowledge and so
jesus said i don't know how to do this simply give information watch this this is very very very
important whenever i speak i want the good which i manifested to be possessed sam 33 verse nine
i want to give you there he spoke and it came into being god spoke the fiat and all creation
came into being blessed mother spoke the fiat and redemption came into being we have to speak
the fiat for the holy spirit to descend upon the earth we have to it's not a pious thing
it's not something you just feel like doing it's absolutely essential and it's essential for
the history that is unfolding around us listen to it again whenever i speak i want the good which
i manifested to be possessed supposing the lord speaks the word forgiveness into my heart he has
empowered me to forgive and any of this material that we're willing to take on board the lord is
actually empowering us to live it it's not just words it's power therefore be attentive in the
exercise of my will now notice he expects it to be exercised to put into practice that i may open
for you more doors of my knowledge and that you may enter more to receive the design divine possessions
now you and i can walk into the same supermarket and it is full of goodies and most of them as far
as we know are good for you but we don't take everything that's there we choose bits here and
there that we want just now and then if we need more we go back for more well this is what jesus
is saying that when we start out in the divine will we don't actually take a hold of too much
but as we grow an understanding of the enormity of this gift that is offered to us then we reach
out for more and more and more and finally we just say there i lay down my will i'll have the whole
saying and what that reminds me of is Saint Mactimilian Colby at the age of six whose mother had spanked
him and told him he was incorrigible at the age of six he walks straight down to the church walked
up to the altar and he said lord my mother is giving me up and our blessed mother appeared to him
and offered him two crowns the child is only six he has his whole life ahead of him
and she offered him the white crown of purity and holiness in the priesthood
and then being a good psychologist she was holding another one and she was sort of
delaying a little and he said what about that one oh she said that's the red crown of martyrdom
she said it's not given to everybody it's only given to some people you know a special grace
or we said i'll have the two that's what the consecration is he was only six he had his entire
life ahead of him some of us are more than sixty i won't say any more why don't we just give it to
just say yes absolutely fiat so let's come to june the third 1925
louisa asked jesus a question she said i was fusing myself in the holy divine volition
according to my usual way and i was thinking to myself where has our lord god done more
for humanity in the creation in the redemption or in sanctification
and jesus moved in her interior and showed her the whole of creation the only other place that i know
that happened is in the book of job where god took job on a trip around creation and he said
where were you when i made the morning he said where were you when i put the stars in their place
wherever you when i said to the sea thus far and no further and he took him on this marvelous tour of
the universe and of the earth and the result was the job absolutely surrendered and repented
and louisa said how much sublimeness what magnificence is in the earth okay and in creation
how many harmonies what order there's not one point either in heaven or on earth in which god has
not created something special and something distinct that's the details here that are actually very
important and he has created them with such mastery that the greatest scientists before the
smallest thing created by god feel that all their science and mastery is an absolute nothing compared
to things created by god the things created by god are full of life and full of motion now as i
read that our scientists are trying to make artificial intelligence and they're trying to make a kind
of a subspecies of the human race and if you've seen any of these robots there is ugliest the
people who made them and look at a tiny ant just the first creature that comes to my head and
the sheer beauty of the creature particularly if you look at it in in great detail under a microscope
the magnificence of it is incredible and everything that god made have two things that the scientists
can't do they can't give life to it and they can't give motion to it because motion is life god is
the author of life and so the artificial things that they're doing are just incredibly ugly
okay oh how true it is she said that to look at the universe and not recognize god
not to love him and not to believe in him is true fully uh sam fourteen one the fool says in his
heart there is no god but when i was reading this what i've actually written down on my book is
poor norway poor sweden they have the most incredible magnificence scenery all over their
countries and no fate it doesn't make sense and then she said and this is a very important thing
all created things are like many veils that hide him now notice the eucharistic touch there
all created things are like veils that hide the presence of the lord and god comes to us as though
veiled in each created thing because man is incapable of seeing him unveiled now before i get to that
i want you to notice the eucharistic content as i said when the lord talks about living hosts
we are the veils that are hiding his presence when you look at the the mystery of the eucharist
itself that a tiny little bit of bread and the wine are just veils hiding his presence okay
and and here louisa says the whole of creation is veils hiding his presence um we're not capable of
seeing him unveiled in mortal flesh that's exodus 33 verse 20 where moses said let me see your face
and god said no human being cannot see me and live and the reason why god said a human being cannot
see me and live is that you would die of ecstasy if you saw his beauty and glory and god wants you
to complete your journey on the earth so he won't let that happen the love of god for us is so
great that in order not to dazzle us with his light because god is light one john one five
and one timothy six sixteen that he lives in unapproachable light he does not want to frighten
us with his power he does not want us to feel ashamed in front of his beauty because we would
see our own ugliness by comparison with him he doesn't want us to feel annihilated before his
immensity so he veils himself in all created things so as to come to each created thing and to be
with us now what what louisa is saying here the scriptures say very clearly as well and that is
that god really wants to be with the children of men that is proverbs a 31 god delights to be with
the children of men jeremaia 31 3 god loves us with an everlasting infinite absolute eternal love
but he wants to be with us on our journey and when you study the book of exodus you see the immense
trouble that god went to to travel the journey with the chosen people through the wilderness to
the promised land so he veils himself in created things so as to come to each created thing and to
be with us even more to make us swim in his very life my god how much you have loved us how much
you have loved us so for that i want you to read the book of daniel chapter three verses 71 to 85
where the three men in the fiery furnace absolutely break out in praise and glory to god when they
grasp something of his immensity and beauty and power so we continue then after he took me
he made me look at the whole universe my sweet Jesus told me my daughter everything was done in
creation that's the answer to the question she asked did you do more in creation redemption or
sanctification he said everything was done in creation in creation the divinity manifested
all of its majesty power and wisdom and made a display of his complete love towards the creatures
now in this paragraph i want you to notice the divinity he them okay there's not one point either
in heaven or on earth or in any creation thing in which the completeness of our works cannot be seen
so notice the divinity the plurality he and so on so Jesus is making the the three in one very clear
to us so the completeness of our works i want you to look at sam 136 verses one to nine and sam 148
rounds didn't begin with louisa they began in the sams and in other parts of the scriptures
so not one thing was left half done everything is is done in offer completeness in creation god
showed off all his works for his creatures he loved with complete love you see i gave you
due to ronnie six four to ten that we are asked to love god completely here in this answer about
creation uh jesus is saying that god has loved us completely totally absolutely with all his heart
all his whole being so god loved the human race with complete love and did complete works
there was nothing to be added or to be removed now notice this now watch the change here
so i did everything because jesus is the second person of the trinity so i did everything now
if you just take those words i did everything and go back into the scriptures you'll be amazed
he's all over the scriptures i did everything nor can we notice the i and the way do incomplete
works on the contrary in creation a distinct and complete love towards each creature was placed
in each created thing now what you have to do with that sentence is take it off the book
look at it and realize that there is a distinct love that god has given to us in all of creation
and we kind of know this instinctively because we want to see the mountains and the hills and the
rivers and the waterfalls we want to see the the huge variety in creation we want to have a huge
variety in our gardens as well there is a distinct love so he said going on to answer her about
redemption he said redemption was nothing other than reparation for the evils the creatures that
the humanity had done it added nothing to the work of creation and sanctification did nothing other
than help uh offer help grace light so that man could return to his original state and creation
so here jesus is saying that all that was done in redemption and sanctification is to bring us back
to the point where humanity left off because adam and eve were created pure innocent perfect
and in the divine will and therefore for us progress is going backwards we've got to go back to that
single point and pick up from where adam and eve left off so we have to return to our origin and
to the purpose for which we were created in fact in creation the power of god's will the sanctity
by the power of god's will the sanctity of man was complete because adam and eve were created
perfect god can only do perfect things he's not able to do anything that's imperfect because
man had come out of a complete act of god he was holy he was happy in his soul and because my will
brought to him the reflections of the sanctity of his creator he was also holy and happy in his
body as well so there you have what we know is the bliss of eden that we've all been very much aware
of before the fall and my daughter jesus said in spite of redemption and the work of sanctification
the sanctity of man is incomplete and for some it is as though useless because not only are they
not giving a response to the revelation about the divine will they're not giving a response
to redemption either this says that if man does not turn back now this turning back is extremely
important as i said progress is going backwards turning back is this metanoia
the human beings have got to start thinking differently to the way they're thinking now
if man does not turn back in order to take my will as life as rule and as food to be purified
ennobled and divinized and to take the first act of creation so as to take my will as his inheritance
assigned to him by god the very works of redemption and sanctification will not have their copious
effects so we've got to turn around and really in consecrating ourselves to the lord we are reaching
out for his divine will as life as rule as food we're asking to be purified ennobled and divinized
we're asking him to enable us to receive this inheritance and to carry this inheritance
for the whole of humanity to enable him to work in us and through us for them so that the whole
humanity will benefit god loves everybody and he loves each person in the same way he loves the
whole and he loves the whole like each person as well so we cannot say it's not for them and it's
not for them it's for every single living being so he said everything is in my will if someone takes
the divine will he takes everything so in making our consecration we're saying fiat yes yes to
everything that the divine will is the divine will as he has told us a number of times already
is one single point a singularity that contains everything past and future everything is present
to god in fact there's no past and future he's outside of time and space it's one single point
and it embraces and encloses the goods of redemption and of sanctification even more for one who lives
in my will because he has taken the first point of creation all these goods serve him
not as a remedy as it does for those who don't do the divine will but they serve him as glory
and as his special inheritance carried upon the earth by the will of the celestial father in the
power of the person of the word everything coming to us from the father through the son to us
so I want to give you Hebrews 9 15 and I want to give you Colossians 1 12
and then Jesus said and if I came to the earth the first act was precisely to make known
the will of the father that is the most important thing to make it known loved accepted lived
so that heaven can come down to earth that's what he wants thy kingdom come on earth so I did this
in order to bind the will of god to the human creatures the pains the humiliations my hidden
life and the whole immense sea of the pains of my passion were remedies medicines supports
and light in order to make my will known because with this I would have man not only save but holy
with my pains I placed him in safety now him is the whole human race with my will I gave him back
the sanctity lost in the terrestrial Eden that's why we've got to go back and take it up from there
had I not done this my love my work would not have been complete as they were in creation
because my will alone has the power of rendering our works complete towards the creatures
so the divine will alone has the power of rendering the divine works complete for us
and the works of creatures towards us so in other words the divine will is the only thing that can
complete of what god actually wants in us and through us now watch this my will makes a person
think differently now this is where the transformation is you have if you go to Proverbs 23 7 you will
read as a man thinks so is he in other words we say you are what you think and so what you think
is absolutely essential and here Jesus is saying that the divine will enables us to think as god
thinks you remember Jesus as part of his controversy with describes and Pharisees said to them I think
it in either john 7 or 8 he said you can't even hear my language they were so outside of the way
he was thinking that there was no possibility of communication between them and it was very
frustrating for him that they couldn't grasp the simplest thing that he was saying and so it is
with us if we speak to very worldly people also they would have no idea what we're speaking about
either so the divine will makes us think differently we think the way god thinks it makes one look at
my will in all created things so it makes you see things differently also if a worldly person
is looking at things they're looking at it for worldly purposes and very often that is for a
personal game but the divine will makes you see the divine will in all created things it makes you
speak with the echo of the divine will it makes you operate through the veils of the divine will
now notice this is a complete transformation of our being in a word one does everything all at once
according to the supreme volition this complete transformation of our beings to your thought words
actions all operate in the divine will and therefore at this higher plane the other virtues he said
absolutely and little by little my redemption by itself even without the first act of my will
serves to dress the deepest wounds it serves as medicine for man so as not to let him die that's
die spiritually it serves as an antidote so as not to let him fall into hell and therefore take to
heart my will alone so this consecration is i choose you i choose you forever i choose all that
you are forever he said take my will to heart if you really want to love me and if you want to
make yourself a saint interesting so let's go to june the 11th 1925
the good that one loses by not doing the divine will is irreparable so luisa said i felt my poor
mind immersed in the most holy will of god oh how i wished i would do not even want breath one heartbeat
one movement outside of the divine will so this is asking for complete immersion she is actually
completely immersed but i think that the lord is getting her to say this for our sake that we're
the ones who need to move into the complete immersion it seemed to me that everything which
was done outside of the will of god makes one lose new beauty now notice the word new to lose new
beauty to lose new grace and light and it places us in dissimilarity to our creator
while jesus wants us to be similar to our supreme maker in everything now similar what does that
mean god is light god is love just take those two and you'll see just where we have got to go
god is wisdom god is beauty god is just god is merciful it can go down through all the attributes
okay he wants us to be similar and that is clearly stated in genesis 127 let us make man in our own
image okay want to give you one john three two as well because to be similar to him we have to
have all sin behind us and in what easier way can we be like him other than receiving into ourselves
the continuous life of his most holy will continuous every moment of every day that's the commitment
we're looking for the divine will brings us the reflections and the features of our celestial
father that means we become like god the divine will maintains whole within us the purpose of creation
the divine will surrounds us in such a way as to preserve us beautiful and holy that we've been
hearing jesus in the last number of volumes telling us that the thing that the divine will does in
creation is that it preserves creation it preserves it exactly as he wanted it to be so everything is
fresh and beautiful and we should we see this every time we look at the flowers and we look at the
fruits on the trees it's they're so attractive there's they're so marvelous even just to look
at them let alone taste them the divine will surrounds us in such a way as to preserve us
beautiful and holy there's a sam i've just remembered at this moment i can't remember the
number of it but it says serve the lord in the beauty of holiness there is a beauty about holiness
that if a person is holy within somehow even if their face was very plain there is something that
shines forth that changes the face completely it preserves us beautiful and holy as god
created us and it gives us that something i like the way she says that's something ever knew of beauty
and light and love which is never interrupted in other words we're divinized which can be found
only in god so if this is true then moving out of the divine will is a disaster so this is what
we're having in the next paragraph now while my mind was wandering in the eternal volition my
sweet jesus clasping me to himself with a sensible voice so she's hearing it outside of herself
said my daughter there is nothing which can equal the great evil of not doing my will now
notice that great evil of not doing my will there's no good that can equal the divine will
there is no virtue that can stand before the divine will so the good that one loses by not
doing the divine will is irreparable look at the word that is used and only by returning again
into the divine will can you find the remedy and can you be given back the goods which our will
had established to give to the creature now that is the the state that people are in in the early
stages of living this divine will wonder and that is that they could be in and out of the divine will
quite frequently but then eventually you have to move towards laying the whole of your being down
before god so jesus continues in vain do they flatter themselves that they can do more works and
more virtues and more sacrifices if these are not a birth from my will in other words if they are
not a divine will act there and if they're not done in order to fulfill the divine will
they're not even recognized by me so we could waste an enormous amount of our religious lives
i want to give you matthew seven twenty one two twenty seven where jesus says some people are going
to say lord lord did we not work miracles in your name did we not cast out demons in your name and
he said i don't know you i find that frightening i don't know about you more so he said it is established
now established where it's actually established in the torah the first five books of the old testament
it's established that grace aids light goods and just reward are given to one who operates
in order to fulfill the divine will let me give you an example in the torah deuteronomy twenty eight
verses one to fourteen and deuteronomy thirty verses fifteen to twenty you get the blessings
and the curses the blessings that go with doing god's will and the disasters that you bring upon
yourself by doing your own will moreover he said my will is eternal and of course immutable and what
people today in our rebellious society thinks that they can change the ten commandments if god said
that this was the way human beings had to live what god says is eternal it can't be changed
moreover my will is eternal it has no beginning as is no end so who can calculate the value
of a single act in the divine will which is no beginning in no end and how can you compare that
to a human act which comes and goes and may or may not even have value
that which my will is he said it renders the act when we put something into the divine will
the divine will he said that act is surrounded and filled with goods without end that which my will
is it also renders that act on the other hand the other virtues the works and the sacrifices
without my will have a beginning and have an ending and what great reward can things subject
to parishing have and then he goes on to talk about the balance that is in god and the balance
that needs to be in us i think this is fascinating furthermore he said my will is the balance
of my attributes you know the church has always told us that virtues in medios that virtue walks
the middle road it's balanced so something like the extreme is out of balance whether it's extreme
right or extreme left it's out of balance by the very fact of being extreme so he's talking about
the balance he said and he gives an example which is very very interesting if my power he said
did not have this holy will it could in unfold into tyranny towards those who so much offend me
while by balancing my power my will makes me pour graces there when i should pour fury and
destruction now what you have here is that justice and mercy balance wisdom and beauty balance and
he goes through all of the when he doesn't go through all of them but you make a list of the divine
attributes and watch that they actually balance each other in the most wonderful way so when you're
hearing in these writings a lot about justice it's balanced by mercy when you hear about mercy
it has to be balanced by justice because he's going to show you that that mercy could become
soft and it could actually become destructive mercy has to be balanced by justice so it's
wonderful what he says if it were not for my will which gives every new life my wisdom would not
manifest so much art and mastery in our works our beauty would be faded and would be without
attraction if it were not sustained by my eternal will mercy could turn into weakness
if it were not balanced by my will now we see mercy turned into weakness for example
when parents give into their children and don't deal with them wisely
and so with all the rest of our attributes he said our paternal goodness has so much love
won john four seven towards humanity that it has established the balance of man within our will
so since we have to be like him there has to be a balance in us as well so we have to have the
justice with mercy and the mercy with justice we also have to have the wisdom with beauty and
beauty with wisdom otherwise beauty can take over the balance within man so i want to give you john
fifteen nine as the father has loved me so i have loved you so since man had come out of the supreme
will it was right that his will make itself this will this divine will make itself the life
and maintain the balance in all the operating of man there's something beautiful about
seeing a person well balanced and really mature in that balance there's something very attractive
about it so it wanted to put the divine will as the life and to maintain the balance in all the
operating of man giving him the lightness of his creator genesis to seven because it was only when
the spirit was poured into man that the lightness was given so such dignity majesty and order in acting
were to be seen in him as to make him recognized as a product of his maker Romans 829 that god wanted
that human beings could look at a person and know that god lived because this person is god like
look at the way we're meant to pass the message on to others in the most wonderful way and you can
do it with totally without words just by being the fullness of what god has actually created you to
be i think it's wonderful because many people worry about what do i say to people and my own
feeling is as little as possible would be everything therefore jesus said also from the way that people
act it can be seen whether there is the balance of my will or that of the human will and so it would
become very obvious to anybody you lived with or anybody you worked with whether you were operating
on the higher plane of divine will or the lower plane of the human will they mightn't have those
words but they would know whether it was the higher or the lower and this is the cause of so
many works maybe even good ones in which however the balance the regime the rule of life order
cannot be seen in other words there's some kind of extreme in it the execution of my will is missing
therefore instead of being admired they're blamed and instead of shedding light they cast
darkness if all that is good comes from my will then without it they are only apparent goods
without life and maybe even poisonous which poisoned those who take part in them now when i was
meditating on this i wrote down two examples of my chocchio certainly if you don't know enough about
what goes on in the charge at my chocchio and that is priests and religious live a celibate life
so they should be living up there okay but there's many a priest who has reproduced himself
in a church building in other words that's my building that's my creation so it's his creation
it's not god's creation it's reflecting him it's not reflecting god and many religious has
reproduced himself himself or herself in a hospital building or a school or whatever it is that's my
work that's what i produced there's my signature you'll always know that i was on the planet there's
my signature there's that wonderful building architects can do the same thing painters can do
the same thing any of us can do the same thing that's mine that's a signature of me and jesus is saying
that if it's only the product of the human will it isn't much use there's no value to it
so i want to go to june the 18th 1925 and i have a vip on this one how all things contain the seed
of regeneration louisa said i was fusing myself in the holy divine volition according to my usual way
and as that immense empty space the divine will of the most holy supreme will came before my mind
i thought to myself how can it ever be that this void would be filled by the requital of the human
acte done in the adorable divine will i mean it's so empty she said how on earth could you fill it
in order to do this all the barriers of the human will would have to be removed
Matthew 7 21 Matthew 18 3 and all these barriers which prevent the step in order to enter into this
eternal and celestial sphere of the supreme will in which it seems that god awaits these acts
so that man may return to his origin in the order of creation and return to those first steps and
path in which he had his beginning now very clearly she has pointed out something here
there's no problem about going forward into the divine will you just have to remove the barriers
you remember jesus in john chapter 11 when he stood before what everybody considered
the impossible he stood before a tomb of rotten death and he said something that puzzled them all
he said remove the stone he wasn't going to remove the stone he didn't put it there
he said you remove the stone you removed the barrier and when they eventually did remove
the barrier then the divine call went into that tomb calling the man out of death into life
we're there to remove the barrier and so in the early days of living in the divine will and
we're dealing with stuff in the early volumes we are actively putting these barriers away
we're actively removing the stone so that we can be called into this new level in the divine will
and then louisa is looking at society today and she said but nothing new of any good can be seen
in the world this is 1925 in between two world wars since have remained the way they were and
they seem to be worse and if so awakening can be heard of religion of pure works in catholic
circles they seem to be masked with that good but deep inside in their substance there are such
vices as to be horrifying more than ever before now notice again the external action what if the
source is wrong as there's no value now notice she used the term masked you're talking about 1925
and those of you who are doing the book of revelation with me deception was the big thing
and here she talks about deceptive works they appear to be okay on the outside but inside
their rotten so how can it ever be that man may give death to all devices as though in one blow
to give life to all the virtues as is required in order to live in the sphere of the divine will
we have to remove the stone okay so the answer Jesus gives is fantastic in fact in order to live
in the divine will oh sorry it's still louisa at the moment and i just have underlined this because
it is so important for our consecration in fact in order to live in the divine will there are no
compromises there are no lives divided between virtues and vices the vices are oh you too
rather it is necessary to sacrifice everything that volumes one to four
so as to convert all things into the divine will of god
now if i went looking for teaching on the consecration i couldn't find better
so i want to give you luke 1433 and i want to give you luke 1613 luke is very strong
on you have to sacrifice everything okay and you can also take luke 1822
so it is necessary to sacrifice everything so as to convert all things into the will of god
the human will and human things must have life no more simple
simply turn they must exist in order to fulfill the will of god in them
so that the divine will may carry its life within us and my reaction to that
section is corban given hand it over so in the next paragraph now when i was thinking about
this and other things my sweet jesus interrupting my talk told me might over yes it will be so
so she's looking at the the sinfulness of humanity and the impossibility
of the divine will actually raining on earth and he said but it will be so because if god
decrees something it will happen even if he has to wait centuries for it
so beside that i want to give you amos three seven that god never does anything without
telling the prophets first so my daughter yes it will be so this immense void of my will
will be filled with human acts done by creatures in my will and i said thanks be to god it's wonderful
so there are generations not yet born who will live in the divine will more fully than you and i do
my will came out of the eternal womb of the supreme being for the good of man
while this will of ours did one single act one feat in coming out of us in order to
overwhelm man in such a way that he might find no way out and now if you're coming to the
revelation class tomorrow you're going to hear more about this notice he says he's going to
overwhelm the human race to get his way it's very interesting and we'll do it in such a way
that he might find no way out so the divine will multiplies itself into many innumerable acts in
order to surround man and to say to him see this will of mine not only envelopes you
but it is continuously making immediate acts to make itself known and to receive
the requiting act in the divine will the lord is continuously coming towards you at every second
of your life and he's looking for this response you know the way in training children the parent
will say thank you mom reminding the child the child needs to give a response say thank you say
sorry to your little brother or your little sister or whatever it is we actually remind them and
the lord reminds us that we have to give this continuous response to him as well all things
receive their return and jesus explaining at now the logic of us responding to god and if they don't
they can be called useless works without any value for example number one the seed sold by the
the sore under the earth wants its return that the seed generate more seeds 10 20 30 times more
too the tree planted by the farmer wants its return of the generation and multiplication
of its fruits number three the water drawn from the fountain gives its return of quenching one's thirst
of washing and cleaning for the one who has drawn it number four the fire that has lit gives the
return of warming in the same way all other things created by god who has the power to generate
contain the power of regeneration they multiply and they give their return
now is only this will of ours which came out of us with so much love and with so many manifestations
and with so many continuous acts to remain without its return of the regeneration of the human
wills in the divine so there's the logic it's already happening in creation it will happen in humanity as
well a seed gives more seeds a fruit generates more fruit man generates another man and i love
the next one a teacher generates another teacher that's what we've been up to creating more teachers
for the divine will is our will alone powerful as it is to remain isolated without a return and
without regenerating our will in the human will and always that that would be impossible
that would that would mean a break from the pattern that you see in all of creation
our will will have its return i say alla luya
it will have its divine generation in the human will more so since this was our first act for
which all things were created that our will would transform and regenerate the human will
into the divine this is God's absolute will it's not his permissive will it is absolute will
will is what came out of us small will human will is what we want
so we all know now that if we want to please god we know exactly what he wants and that's the gift
of our will all other things were done in the secondary order while this was done established
in the primary order of creation at the most it may take time but the centuries will not end
until my will obtains its purpose god has extraordinary patience if it has obtained the
purpose of regeneration and secondary things much more must the divine will obtain in its primary
purpose our will would never have departed from our womb if it knew that it would not
obtain its complete effects because don't forget god is omniscient he knows everything
and that is uh that the human will would be regenerated in the divine so i want to give you
Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 11 that uh my way my ways are not like your ways and my thinking is not
like your thinking in fact my ways are as different from yours as the heavens are from the earth is
what the lord told Isaiah so god is omniscient he knows it's going to happen so uh our response
to this is that we have this immense privilege of being part of it the immense privilege that
is he's added me in as well so he continues do you think that things will always be as they are today
he said ah no and my reaction to that is please god no my will will overwhelm everything that is
the tribulation in the book of revelation for those of you who are doing revelation with me
you'll find this in chapter revelation six revelation eight to nine and revelation 16
my will will overwhelm everything it will cause confusion everywhere it's going to upset everything
all things will be turned upside down many new phenomena will occur such as to confound the pride
of man i say thanks be to god there will be wars there will be revolutions there will be casualties
of every kind will not be spared in order to knock man down now if you go to Isaiah chapter two
you'll understand knock man down because three times in Isaiah chapter two and the prophet keeps
saying the pride of man must be brought low the pride of man must be brought low i think it's in
verse seven uh eleven and nineteen something like that the pride of man must be brought low and that's
what jesus is saying here we need to knock man down uh but not to destroy him it's to dispose him
to open him up to enable him to actually begin to see the way god sees to dispose him to receive
the regeneration of the divine will in the human will and everything i manifest to you about my will
as well as everything you louise do in it it's nothing other than preparing the way the means
the teachings the light the graces so that my will may be regenerated in the human will so i want to
give you jara maya twenty nine eleven creating a future full of hope for them if this were not to
occur i would not have manifested so much to you nor would i have kept you sacrificed in a bed
for such a long time in order to lay in you the foundations of the regeneration of my will in yours
and therefore keep you in continuous exercise look at the word continuous within my will
do you think that my continuously being with you feeding you my prayer making you feel my pains
which together with me acquire a different value showing you different effects and different power
do you think that's trivial i could say that i am making the first statue and that may seem a
very strange statement watch this i could say i'm making the first statue the first soul of the
regeneration of my will then making facsimiles will be easier now you have to go back to genesis
chapter two and you're told that god fashioned man out of the clay of the earth that means it was
like making a statue and then he breathed the breath of life into this statue and man became a living being
you're told in the gospels that jesus went to enormous trouble to fashion the new church
in the twelve apostles well he only got eleven in the end but they were like the inert atom they
couldn't do anything until after the resurrection he breathed the breath of life into them and the
church became a living being so here you have the first of the new creation and the rest of us are
the facsimiles so this is why i always say to you be attentive for this is about something too great
and about the most important thing that exists in heaven and on earth this is about placing the
rights of the divine will in safety that's number one two it is about giving back to god the purpose
of creation three by returning to god all the glory for which all things were made and four
about making god give all the graces which his will had established to give to creatures
had they fulfilled our will in everything what a wonderful thing to aim at it's absolutely incredible
so what the lord wants is to place the rights of his will in safety to give back to the blessed
Trinity the purpose of the creation that they brought into being to return to them all the glory
for which everything they they made and to make them give all the graces which
their will had established to give to creatures if we hadn't blocked it and blocked it and blocked
i'm going to stop there it's a very wonderful thing to take on board and i think very good for
our preparation for the divine will so i just want to finish by saying glory be to the father
and to the son and to the holy spirit as it was in the beginning is now and ever shall be
world without end amen and thank you for joining us